let's get back to the phones we take
calls every friday through the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at
davidpakman.com
slash discord
let's hear from folks like oh i don't
know
how about james from southern california
james welcome
uh thank you very much can you hear me i
can hear you fine james
excellent um well first of all thank you
so much for everything you've done over
the years thank you i
wanted to ask your opinion on uh
something
what do you think
the reality is of
us eliminating the electoral college
system and what would be the path to
that if it is a reality i see it as an
almost impossibility through
constitutional amendment this would be
one way to change the electoral college
it would be to actually have a
constitutional convention and and change
the way that it functions
i see that as almost an impossibility
the more likely scenario is something
called the national popular vote
interstate compact the way this works is
individual states can decide they can
decide to assign their electoral votes
however they want
normally what states do is they say
whoever wins our state gets the
electoral votes but states can say
instead we're going to give our
electoral votes to whoever wins the
national popular vote so you could have
a state like for example pennsylvania
say
in the future
we're not going to pay attention to
whether trump or biden win pennsylvania
we're going to pay attention to whether
trump or biden get more votes nationally
and that's who will get pennsylvania's
electoral votes does that part make
sense james how that would work
yes it does so it sounds like
pretty much if we want to achieve this
we'd have to start rallying on the state
level and the thing is a bunch of states
have already signed up for this and of
course for it to go into force
you need enough states to do it
such that their electoral votes would be
more than the 270 that one needs to
become president but the problem is
we're getting we've got a lot of the
blue states some red states or at least
purple states are going to need to come
aboard and so that's the that's the
challenge right now but i see that as a
way more likely way to get to a national
popular vote than a constitutional
amendment
sounds good at least there's some
reality they're pulling it off yeah yeah
it's not an impossibility but it's also
you know this is not everyone's top
priority i think it's fair to say yeah
and that's that's the problem it's a
long shot people aren't pushing for it
we've got all these important short-term
things to deal with exactly that just
falls by the wayside well thank you so
much for your time david i appreciate it
all right my pleasure there is james
from southern california
making a number of important
declarations